hunter hunter is back and not only is it
back but at first higashi confirmed four
chapters then that became 10 chapters
and now it is 20 chapters hello and
welcome to the new world review your
source for the most exciting scribbly
circles of all time my name is liam and
we have some major hunter hunter
announcements more chapters confirmed
returning characters and some
tantalizing speculation for the futures
but first and foremost togashi took to
the twitter as he does these days and he
confirmed that manuscripts for 10 more
chapters of hunter hunter have been
completed and just clarify what this is
these are the storyboard giraffes which
in manga is known as names if you get
why they're known as names bakuman
taught me this at one point but they are
but apparently togashi has also finished
the inking for these 10 chapters which
is very very exciting because from there
they basically just need editing type
setting probably a bit more editing and
then bam publish and given that the
initial goal was to start releasing
chapters once they had a stockpile of 10
this means that the reality of hunter
hunter returning could be upon us very
very soon also this video is sponsored
by displate one of a kind metal posters
designed to capture your unique passions
whatever they may happen to be for
example my unique passion is this duck
and just how chunk it is i'm essentially
going to stick this on the back of my
bathroom door just so that guests can be
reminded as they are
doing the thing that they will never
ever ever be as good as this duck you
can customize collect and rearrange your
displays and have them up in under 20
minutes due to the ridiculously easy and
safe magnetic mounting system no power
tools no wall damage just 100 magnetic
ducky glory but duck alternatives are
also available as display works with a
wide range of specific artists that do
absurdly cool work as well as official
brands such as the witcher the marvel
and the star wars display is just such a
great alternative to paper and canvas
and wood and you know and any other
miscellaneous material that is not this
and it's even cheaper because if you
click the link in the description you
will receive a discount on all of your
glorious new wall coverings which is 25
off two displays and 29 off three so go
do that thing but for now back to you me
but also togashi announced that while
these chapters are in the editing phase
he is going to begin work on a further
10 which gives us a confirmed goal of 20
new hunter hunt chapters and i mean just
ah when it comes to hunter hunter 20 is
a number so large that it feels like the
equivalent of echo oda deciding you know
i'm gonna dump a couple of hundred one
piece chapters on you and i could not be
more thrilled to hear this though
whatever the non-kfc equivalent of
japanese christmas is i am excited as
crap when this announcement was first
made i was just stoked at the
possibility of three to four chapters so
20 is beyond anything that i could have
hoped for and it's such a meaty story
stack that i think it's worth becoming
legitimately invested in hunt hunter
again if you're on the fence thinking
that yeah it'll be back for a little bit
and then take a hiatus fairly
immediately 20 chapters is a lot
especially with the sheer amount of
information that togashi likes to cram
into them it's starting for the first
time maybe ever i should say but it is
starting to give me hope that the
succession war arc will actually have a
conclusion and if you're counting along
at home then you're strange and stop
doing that but for everyone else this
stack of 20 would allow hunter hunter to
finally break through the 400 chapter
barrier and land us at chapter 410 there
are currently more chapters in
production right now than there have
been for the last five years and it's
quite an ingenious but necessary
strategy usually mangaka is only about
three to four chapters ahead of most and
even that ends up being a pretty rough
deadline to meet so i do like the idea
that togashi has a solid 10 ready to go
which even if they're all published in a
row with no breaks gives togashi 10
weeks to build up another batch which is
about exactly the time we needed for the
initial 10. togashi announced that he
was working on new chapters on may 24th
so in roughly 2 months he has penned 10
chapters that's pretty wild when you
think about it because most weekly
mangaka would have made six to eight
grant they would have been fully edited
and probably far more complex in terms
of art but still this this is extreme
productivity and the way togashi is
doing this is almost like the manga
equivalent of making a seasonal anime
but as part of this ever so exciting
news we now know that chapter 391 the
first in this batch is essentially
complete and just undergoing its final
editorial phase so somewhere out there i
guess japan but somewhere out there
there is a complete hunter hunter
chapter just ready for consumptions i'm
not sure if they'll move to release it
when 391 is 100 complete or if they'll
wait for all 10 to be at that stage but
my mouth is starting to water at the
prospect of some new hunter hunter and
togashi has gotten gradually more bold
with his teaser images i mean most of
them do consist of circles and more
circles and occasionally some scribbles
but on one fate someday togashi revealed
a full drawing of karapika a tweet that
received almost a million likes and
tagashi himself now has almost three
million twitter followers and he follows
zero people so what a boss and also a
few days earlier he posted this drawing
of a mystery figure who i think looks
suspiciously like a maybe kaluto zoldick
again maybe it's hard to tell without
the whole face thing people tend to be
quite anonymous without those but if
you're a hunter hunter fan and a twitty
user then i'm sorry for the second but
go and give togashi a follow because i
think that the colossal engagement he
receives could be helping to fuel this
productive streak i don't think that he
or anyone anticipated just how well this
would be received and how anticipated
the return of this manga would be and he
does drop updates daily so give those
tweets a like if you can and let's
encourage this man to finish his
masterpiece but now to your thoughts i'm
extremely excited but i'm also really
looking forward to another physical
volume because i like to collect and i
think a volume 37 would look amazing on
my shelf yes good point currently the
last volume published was 36 which is
peppered by all of these delightful
chibi phantom troop members however the
weird thing now there are currently 10
unpublished chapters which is actually
enough to release an entire volume i
mean volume 36 it only has 10 chapters
so 37 could have been released years and
years and years ago and i'm not entirely
sure why they didn't but having said
that i'm not entirely sure i'm pretty
sure it's a money thing i imagine it
would be better to release the book when
there's some new material and since
there hasn't been any new material then
they've been sitting on the book they've
been sitting on it for so so long it's
kind of annoying though because those
chapters 381 onwards are kind of a pain
in the ass to find officially in english
they aren't available on the viz website
because it only sells volumes and as far
as i'm aware the only legal way to get
them is to individually buy each issue
of the english shonen jump that they
were published in which is such a screw
around at that point that i'm just like
no
scans for this it is i'm seriously
concerned for togashi sensei's health i
just hope these chapters aren't too much
for him and he can continue to work
without putting his body into too much
stress so in case anyone doesn't know
due to togashi's legitimately crippling
health issues he can only draw in a very
unique position about a month ago he
released a message about his art
exhibition and revealed that currently
he can only draw while slaying down like
so he also goes into a lot of detail
about how difficult daily life has been
for him like a lot of potentially
unnecessary detail including the fact
that he has to have a shower after every
time he takes a dump because he is
unable to wipe he didn't need to know
that but i do now and i don't know what
to do with this information so tagashi
is actually a bit of a pioneer at the
moment unable to draw while sitting or
even sit while sitting he is developing
his own backup style of lie down manga
and if anything it makes me appreciate
even more that he is actually still
continuing if i was in his position i
would probably just go you know what
this this thing just isn't getting done
i know it's probably not gonna happen
but i just want to see or know more
about the dark continent it's always
been a huge mystery that i've been dying
to know maybe some more don freak's info
you say it's probably not going to
happen but 20 chapters like like i said
is a lot if togashi really wanted to he
could probably finish this entire war in
20 chapters especially with his habit of
abrupt endings and even if not the
quantity of material incoming could
contain several dark continental nuggets
especially if we finally get some
information regarding jing and paristan
those two are practically inseparable
from dark continent material and they've
got to be making their way there somehow
so there's some hope look i'm not going
to say a lot but some certainly more
than we've had for the past half a
decade or so i'd love to see hisoka
killing more spiders i feel the ship is
starting to get close to the oh god
we're all gonna die stage yeah yeah
that's a good point i've been hesitant
to speculate on this but with 20
chapters i think it's entirely possible
that we are going to end up with some
dead troop members certainly some dead
princes but that wasn't the question if
i was to pluck out the first victim then
part of me would want to turn to
franklin simply because he's all alone
and a relatively easy target compared to
everyone else hisoka could kill murder
him without anyone knowing at the same
time though hisoka allegedly isn't on
tier 5 at the moment and if that wild
theory that he is illumi turns out to be
true then nielem is on tier 3. so maybe
right now in a bit of a weird way
franklin is the most safe of all of the
troops the only other person on their
own is machi but it's hard to see her
being the first victim after togashi
very purposely kept her alive everyone
else is tricky because they're all in
like their funky groups but having
mentioned it if philami does turn out to
be hisoka then i suppose kalito is
currently in a pretty bad spot to say
the least honestly i'm most looking
forward to the community discussion and
resurgence in youtube videos about
hunter hunter hmm me too it's been a
very very lonely few years there are
some points where i felt that i was the
only one who still cared about hunter
hunter but you guys really proved me
otherwise by continuing to watch these
videos
for some reason so i really can't wait
for other creators to jump back on the
wagon and revitalize this whole space
because honestly i often look forward to
discussing the chapters with people far
more than actually reading them i'm
watching the anime and hisoka netero and
coin butler are my favorite characters i
hope we see more of them story uh yeah
i'm sure we'll see a lot more of all
three of those very alive and well
characters i am most looking forward to
the eventual return of another anime arc
or two all right look i i don't want to
be too insanely optimistic but this does
legitimately open up that potential
because really as soon as the succession
war arc is complete there could very
easily be a sequel series of the 2011
anime that lasts somewhere around 50
episodes because by the time our next
two batches are out this part of the
story will have 70 whole chapters ready
to adapt there was also a bit of a false
alarm for the anime returning thanks to
togashi or more accurately thanks to the
western fanbase he posted an image on
twitter which featured the fuji tv logo
and western fans including myself raised
a very speculative eyebrow however if
you could read japanese and you would
know it's an old no it's nothing to get
excited about it would be hard to
believe that another anime series isn't
something on the cards here though
shueisha tv networks and anime studios
are kind of like reverse vultures
perpetually circling the home of togashi
just waiting for him to spring to life
again and being given a license to print
some more money i don't know though do
you guys think that we could finish the
succession war in 20 chapters leave your
answers in the place knowing togashi the
storyboards are probs the final product
le mao yeah again there's always the art
comment here's the thing though togashi
has published some very objectively poor
chapters in the series history that is
inarguable but this new system gives me
a lot of hope because it allows togashi
to take his time there's no urgency to
publish and so no pressure to just push
out storyboards and call them completed
chapters so i think this could work out
quite well the inevitable live-action
hunter hunter announcement no no no no
no no no stop it i mean with that said
another one of togashi's works is
getting a live-action adaptation and it
is you you haka show and i i don't know
how to feel about this i get that these
are just promo images but karama and
here in particular
they do not fill me with confidence
because promotional material and weirdly
enough it's meant to promote and
showcase the best of what you have to
offer and if this is the best then i'm
going to remain pretty damn skeptical
tell you what though the most positive
thing i can say about this is that it
really makes me appreciate what we've
seen of the live action one piece so far
i still think that is one of the world's
most difficult tasks to pull off but
they have at least passed the initial
test that you haka show i think has
certainly failed with hunter hunter
though i was about to say that it
wouldn't be the most difficult thing in
the world to make live action not for
the first few arcs anyway then i also
remembered that our protagonists are
pre-teens which leaves you with the
choice of either aging them up or
somehow finding some pretty damn
miraculous child actors or and then just
hear me out here don't do it instead go
and watch another fun video thing which
is right here and i look forward to
seeing you there